buongiorno ragazzi l'abbiamo fatta in
molti modi
abbiamo fatta francese l'abbiamo fatta
romana adesso era il modo
di reinventare ancora una volta la
carbonara che forse possiamo dire uno
dei grandi piatti di questa rubrica di
cucina buttata seguendo un bel po di
consigli che sono arrivati sei su
youtube e su instagram di provare a fare
il grande salto
il salto è il grande salto è quello di
fare una esistono un sacco di ricette su
youtube
alla fine siamo riusciti a trovare forse
quella lì che a metà tra roba semplice
semplice semplice è quella lì troppo
difficile faremo fondamentalmente la
carbonara regala di uno chef un ragazzo
non so che si chiama cristiano bono
l'oman aula blocco nonno comunque questo
cristiano che ringraziamo ci mettiamo
anche l'incasso ricetta qua sotto
detto ciò partiamo subito perché questa
ricetta sarà meglio difficile sul
disgustoso andante maddalena volta che
vendete visto che gli altri stanno
montando lavorando un'altra una ricerca
di ufficio dove finalmente riusciremo ad
abbandonare questa specie di cunicolo
partiamo subito con 1.800 avremo bisogno
di 320 grammi di spaghetti integrali una
zucchina grande ragazzi se sente
particolarmente ingordi e le tele 2
noi per esempio abbiamo per queste due
un panetto di tofu loro dicono di usare
affumicato io confermo introvabile tra
conferma anzi se qualcuno sa riferimenti
ce lo dica così almeno la facciamo dagli
una cassetta prezzemolo i 100 il
prezzemolo e berta e tanto basta per
render propaganda queste sostituiscono
la pancetta questo che sostituisce
emessa il tofu basa sostituisce in
questi due insieme sostituiscono
concetto è giusto ecco perché serviva
affumicato 200 millilitri di panna di
soia mia ma della curcuma farina di mais
fioretto dice proprio di prendere questa
uno spicchio d'aglio sale pepe olio
abbiamo subito con il procedimento non
ve la prendete legali nel senso io pure
ho avuto esperienza dice italiane legale
della vita che mi hanno fatto volare
siamo cosa fa cagare fa cagare regana
vegetariana un unico vanno ad accordi
resi molto bene io per esempio c'è un
periodo in cui non mangiavo una carne e
la carbonara la facevo questo no
io adoro la carbonara di torno e perché
non mangiate la carne
ti ricordi che mi dispiaceva pensiero
che se stessero animali di serie animali
serie b né culture legate al cibo e agli
animali sono molto particolari è sempre
sembrato un po quindi promo per ragioni
etiche per me piaceva e tutti quanti si
chiederanno perché poi ripreso a
mangiare e qui c'è un altro metodo ero
pechino express e questa signora
poverissima povere il cannes
noi stiamo provando di fame ci prepara
l'unico pollo che aveva stretto il cuore
si è stretto il cuore e ho pensato che
io posso dirle che sono un borghese di
merda che può solamente mangiare legumi
e delle cose così se erano una cosa che
aveva giorni si è stretto il cuore l'ho
mangiato grandi sensi colpa poi da lì
però andato avanti perché era molto
presente nelle l'ospitalità di qualche
straniero che tenevo fanno già la carne
per una storia molto belli a cena o non
è molto l'esito ma che mette
l'alternativa sarebbe stata notare alice
mentre l'acqua va verso un pochino di
olio un'anima almeno con l'olio vogliamo
abbondare ma che questa questo periodo
di ristrettezze di spending review ma
che cosa è la gialappa's barry via via
questa cosa l'ho già detto in passato
non mi ricordo quando assieme della
zucchina e quello di tagliarla senza
tagliare e prendere l'anima per
rimuovere la parte interno e questa
parte qui rimarrà verde e più croccante
mamma mia che precisione perché io
questa cosa a volte me la sono fatta con
la zucchina deve scoprire che era meglio
col tonno
non facciamo lasciato davvero problema
della carbonara e che in gran ruolo
gioca luogo è assolutamente assente e
che verrà fatto in un modo che per me un
po il mondo perdonatemi
comunque se voglio sapere di più di
vegetariani vegani compagnia bella
leggetevi le gesta viene da teli se
niente importa di safran foer accesso
alla fiamme non è solo quello spicchio
d'aglio taglio vedi avere più o meno il
tofu dello stesso spessore ma che paura
e me fai questo disturbo degli spezzoni
così almeno a livello visivo
per questo oggi sono così bravo lo staff
ei super disa scarico david perché ci
sei tela che non ci stanno con gli art e
sabotatori la scelta perché io sono nato
annuncia il nò ma non c'è dopo i soldi
come no quelle che stanno tornando
ciao ale rosa dell'himalaya nel tappo
metà tra camerieri trovare un modo per
dargli un pochino più di rocca tezzat
rock ampiezza e sapore visto che non
sono affumicati abbiamo cucinato per un
pochino aggiungiamo anche le zucchine
rocca lecca lecca lecca accademia al
comando non rubi tutele commercio perché
sono si stufano e diventano molle invece
così è più facile che diventino
bloccante specialmente se non least raku
cinica caleca tanto crackati che manco
faranno le tue tanti ragazzi io sono
bravo momento della crema sei pronto
andrebbe a covare nuovo fanno la panna
la panna
wow premia questa farina di mais
1123 cullino di curko male il colore e
per i suoi abitanti cancerose
contro undici minuti perfetto le cinque
sale
sì ma insomma che stai utilizzo infatti
nel dire partoriente dire veramente un
fenomeno velo affittiamo anche perfetto
di compleanno battesimi di un coté
carino qualcosa che ti guarda con quella
riassorbita come chi ha aggiunto un po
di sale la metto la mia amatissima curko
marsi oggi ad ora non c'è una
controparte formaggio zza alcune persone
usano tutti degli strani tipo per menti
cose così che hanno il sapore formaggio
zoe ma il raso di polline eviti una cosa
così perché mi ricorda come hanno fatto
una cultura ma che stramberia vicino
regala però molto simpatico il colore
che questa cosa la trovo buonissima dove
net è andata come vabbè diciamo buona 4
3 2 1 ma allora perché però che fai te
però 30 faccia qualunque quattro
incredibili che odio scolare era la
bravo credo di averla scuola tanto vale
dai poteva andare peggio tra
quest'omicidio di spaghetti integrali un
pochino nell'acqua di cottura
dovremo aggiungere l'uomo come questa
comincia sempre dipende se sta roba
falsificate mi convinse come avevano
fatto la ri bisogno ci sono ci sono ci
sono ci sono pazza però ragazzi che
tagliata al volo che è stata mai tentata
è un po ma lo sposa all'interno acqua di
cottura non è che dobbiamo portare mente
o caso ha sinceramente già la trovo con
una faccia invitante tu sei entrato
quando dico è troppo bene cercherò per
te di farci un impiatta mento a2 un
impianta mento romantico le potete fare
a casa con il vostro ragazzo una persona
quale volete molto bene che rendete come
sempre questo quella mia tecnica
arrotolate la pasta non è carmen sa
benissimo
massa invece è venuto carino non c'ho
sempre doppio attacca che lo piazzo
sopra una rimanenza criterio impianta
mento romantico cosa prevede la via
l'altra porzione più grossa sempre nello
stesso piatto qualche grossa perché era
la mia città e l'intervento di chi non
vuole lavare due piani che il segreto è
prende la pasta ma cercate di avere una
pasta che ebbe cioè figli quella
scivolosa golosa di questa qui è forse
un po troppo però sti cavoli carbonara
vegana signori vi presento una mamma mia
che succede
ecco qui la venia grazie mille per il
tuo aiuto in questo momento numero da
solo questi sono le due paste prima di
assaggiarla vi ricordo sempre di
iscriverlo a questo canale
tutto questo video metterci un pollice
in su ma dove faccia compagnia alla
zucchina e basta mangiamo mangiamo avevo
un pochino hanno elementi cottura il
tipo rasta casa voglio dare fiducia a
file chiuso a me io l'ho fatto come
doveva essere fatta e le trovo anche
molto carino se posso dire la mia è una
buona pasta ma verità ma non ti dovrà
definire il concetto di san giovanno
leggerezza le realtà
evidentemente no la lista è già un
pezzetto di tanto nei momenti più in
saponi profumi che lo sto scoprendo non
è male uguale se ne hai uno passo tocca
qui sotto trovi tu sei un periodo più
alti
però ragazzi suggerirci qualche altra
ricetta vegana no troppo liberi breve
una mediana fattibile ovviamente c'è
secondo quelli che sono i nostri mezzi
cioè convertite c'è il tuo pena no no no
no no ragazzi ci vediamo martedì
prossimo con una puntata del blog
ciao
per vi prometto che avremo prima o poi
con l'ufficio perché queste riprese sono
sempre per dirsi dell'amatorialità vi
chiedo perdono sappiate che ci saranno
delle grandi sorprese
la mia già quale sun che ho pensato
quella